hi there this is steve kaufman um i've
been asked to comment on the language
learning technique known as shadowing
and this was a language learning
technique that is
has been
largely
popularized by professor
argelis
and to learn more about his technique
and how he explains it
i suggest you google or search in
youtube for professor argelius
a-r-g-u-e-l-l-e-s he is a very
accomplished
uh language learner and linguist
uh our shadowing essentially means to to
repeat along
as you are listening to
the language that you're learning and i
think professor argelis particularly
recommends walking around as you do it
so
i do not practice shadowing
that doesn't mean that it's not a good
thing to do
i think there are a lot of things that
can be very effective in language
learning as i have said many times
language learning relies are you know
success in language learning relies on
three elements one is the attitude of
the learner two is the time you spend
with the language with the language not
necessarily in class
and three your ability to notice your
alertness your attentiveness to to the
language
so shadowing certainly um
constitutes time spent with the language
but there are so many things so many
different techniques
uh and some people are going to like
some and not like others
uh i have said before that i'm not a
great fan of
spaced repetition systems i prefer to
control which words i'm going to review
when
i also find that i'm so attracted to
listening and reading and staying with
interesting content
that i just can't find the time to do
some of these other things
when i listen
to a language i largely do so while
doing other tasks i rarely
sort of dedicate myself to listening to
the language hardly at all it's i just
finished doing the dishes and cleaning
up the kitchen there was 20 minutes half
an hour between the pots and everything
else of listening to russian
uh
if i have dedicated time i like to read
so if i'm going to dedicate myself to a
language i'll probably read i won't walk
around
shadowing
i have tried on occasion in the car
trying to repeat along
but but i don't enjoy it i find it it
interrupts my enjoyment of listening so
i prefer to listen
but that doesn't mean that it's not a
good thing to do and i've heard people
say that they find it very effective
it's a bit like pimsleur i don't like
pimsleur
because pimsleur prompts me to say
things
uh answer questions which i don't enjoy
doing
um
for that reason too i don't like
michelle thomas because there's too much
explanation and too much
english in there but other people find
that it's the tremendous way to break
into a language so i think everyone has
to find
whatever way works best for them
um so i mean there's basically my take
on on uh shadowing
i
i i again gets back to this whole idea
of when do we need to speak when do we
need to create output and my belief is
that
you know my practical
needs
as a language learner here in vancouver
learning russian
uh
revolve around developing my
comprehension
uh that is therefore to listen to read
and to increase my vocabulary and i will
do some flashcarding
uh because i find it useful but not in
the expectation i'm going to learn all
those words but simply because it's an
opportunity to reflect on words and how
they're connected and review the phrases
that come with them and so forth
um
but
i i feel no great obligation to speak
however and the reason is very simple
what i like doing in language learning
to me has to be meaningful
so i will speak when it's meaningful to
speak
so if i uh when i'm going to russia now
by the way i'm very happy uh hopefully
if i get my new canadian passport and my
russian visa everything in time then i
should be in russia basically you know
from the 29th of may until about the
11th or 12th of june and when i'm there
i'll be speaking all the time
and i'm quite confident
that with the amount of input-based
learning that i have done
when confronted with a situation where i
need to speak i will gradually start
speaking and i'll speak better and
better so speaking then will be
meaningful
so uh and i'll improve according to the
needs of the situation but right now the
needs of my situation in vancouver where
i have very limited opportunity to speak
my needs are more
to understand what i'm hearing and and i
enjoy that meaningful interaction with
the russian language that i get by
listening to audiobooks or
watching movies or listening to
echamaskview or any of those things and
i have also been increasing my
interaction with our tutors at link and
three four times a week
i will speak to someone in st petersburg
or moscow or previously it was
magnitogorsk
and that was great but i'd do that for
you know two three times a week and uh
it has some impact it makes me aware of
where my problems are
but uh now if i'm thrown into the
frying pan or the fire or whatever of
russia
where every day russian is
is my environment it's on the radio it's
it's i go buy stuff in a store or
whatever i know that my russian will
take a great leap forward and at that
time
output is meaningful but in the meantime
while i'm driving in my car
you know let alone walking around as
professor argelia's recommends which i
would never do i go for a run
listening i can't imagine myself running
listening and shadowing at the same time
uh and i'm a bit of not that way i don't
tend to go for walks because i prefer to
run because that's
within a you know half an hour 40
minutes that's more concentrated
exercise
uh if i go cross-country skiing for two
hours again i'm listening i won't be
shattering because i'm working working
hard so i wouldn't devote myself to
walking around shadowing but even in a
car i find it
tiring and i'm it's it's not meaningful
to me but that's me and i think it's
very important that uh you know if
anyone read my book the linguist you'll
know that i talk about in the first
little intro where i talk about drungs's
crooked tree and how the crooked tree
grows off by itself not in the
plantation forest where all the trees
are are the same the crooked tree
follows its nature and is an
individualist and i think everyone has
to be an individualist and has to find
their own way to their own techniques of
language learning that are most
effective and most most important most
enjoyable for them
all right so i can only tell you what
works for me and what i find enjoyable
and what i think will be effective based
on my experience but everyone has to
find their own way and so shadowing is
undoubtedly very effective for those
people who enjoy doing it and who are
prepared to commit the time to doing it
but that does not include me i don't do
shadowing thank you for listening